aquí está la estructura general para un
cloruro de asilo también llamado cloruro
de ácido y es un derivado del ácido
carboxílicos por lo que podemos formarlo
a partir del ácido carboxílicos si
empezamos con ácidos carboxílicos y
añadimos cloruro de dioni lo podemos
formar nuestro cloruro de asilo y
también formaremos dióxido de azufre y
hcl en esta reacción veamos la
estructura del cloruro de teo nilo por
aquí tenemos el diagrama de puntos y
podemos dibujar una estructura resonante
para éste podemos mostrar a estos
electrones moviéndose al oxígeno
continuamos dibujando lo que formaremos
a partir de eso
nuestro oxígeno ahora tendrá tres pares
libres de electrones dándole una carga
formal de menos 1
nuestro azufre aún estará unido a
estos claros de aquí
tiene también un par libre de electrones
por lo que obtendrá una carga formal de
más 1 así
este es el contribuyente principal a la
estructura en general el oxígeno es
mucho más electro negativo que el azufre
y si pensamos en este enlace pide aquí
hay un traslape ineficiente de los
orbitales p eso es porque el oxígeno y
el azufre están en diferentes periodos
en la tabla periódica el azufre está en
el tercer periodo y tiene un orbital p
mayor que el oxígeno el oxígeno está en
el segundo periodo y entonces aquí
tienes un traslape ineficiente de
orbitales y esa es otra de las razones
de por qué esto contribuirá a la
estructura general además tienes estos
cloro sacchi quitando algo de densidad
electrónica del azufre el cloro es más
electro negativo que el azufre el
resultado final de esto hará a este
azufre
y electro físico y debido a eso nuestro
ácido carboxílicos puede actuar como
nuestro núcleo fino si estos electrones
se mueven acá estos electrones pueden
atacar nuestro azufre por lo que el
núcleo filo ataca nuestro electro filo y
luego estos electrones se mueven al
oxígeno
continuamos mostrando eso
tenemos nuestro grupo r unido a nuestro
carbono y luego eso está enlazado a un
oxígeno el oxígeno tiene dos pares
libres de electrones el oxígeno está
enlazado al azufre
y ahora el azufre está enlazado a este
oxígeno que tiene una carga formal de
menos 1 este azufre está unido a 2
cloros
dibujamos nuestros claros aquí con todos
los pares libres de electrones
aún hay un par libre de electrones en
nuestro azufre
ahora hay un doble enlace entre el
carbono y el oxígeno y un par libre de
electrones en este oxígeno le da una
carga formal de más 1
siguiendo algunos de nuestros electrones
si estos electrones en magenta se mueven
acá
forma nuestro doble enlace y luego
podemos pensar en estos electrones en
azul formando el enlace entre el oxígeno
y el azufre y finalmente podemos pensar
en estos electrones en verde moviéndose
a nuestro oxígeno así y entonces para el
siguiente paso podemos pensar en estos
electrones moviéndose a acá para formar
nuestro doble enlace entre el oxígeno y
el azufre y luego se va el año en
cloruro como nuestro grupo saliente y
sabemos que el año en cloruro es un
excelente grupo saliente por ser estable
por sí mismo cuando dibujemos el
resultado de eso tendremos nuestro grupo
r tendremos nuestro carbono tendremos
ese carbono doblemente enlazado a este
oxígeno con un par libre de electrones y
una carga formal de más 1
y luego tendríamos nuestro oxígeno con
dos pares libres de electrones y nuestro
azufre ahora está doblemente enlazado a
este oxígeno
aún hay un par libre de electrones en el
azufre y sólo un cloro unido al azufre
ahora bien perdimos un año en cloruro
así que continuemos y mostremos algunos
de esos electrones digamos que estos
electrones en rojo se movieron para
formar nuevamente el doble enlace entre
el oxígeno y el azufre y luego tenemos
algunos electrones moviéndose hacia el
cloro por lo que se forma el año en
cloruro así que continuemos y mostremos
eso también estos electrones se movieron
al cloro y obtenemos el año cloruro
continuamos dibujando el año en cloruro
hagamos un poco más de espacio aquí
abajo
también tenemos el año cloruro
que se forma lo dibujamos aquí así con
una carga formal de menos 1 en esta
etapa necesitamos considerar si el año
cloruro funcionará como una base o un
núcleo filo y podrían ser ambos pensamos
primero en el año cloruro
funcionando como una base si funciona
como una base podría tomar este protón
dejando a estos electrones atrás en el
oxígeno
continuamos dibujando lo que formaremos
formaremos nuestro carbón y lo con dos
pares libres de electrones en nuestro
oxígeno luego tendríamos este oxígeno
con dos pares libres
este azufre aún tiene que estar
doblemente enlazado
un par libre y luego el cloro así
estamos diciendo que en esta reacción
ácido base estos electrones se
regresaron acá para formar el carbón y
lo puedes considerar que estos dos son
el intermedio de este mecanismo y verás
que algunas versiones de este mecanismo
tomará este intermedio y continúan
formando tu producto mostraré alan jon
cloruro funcionando como un núcleo filo
por aquí para esto
es una reacción ácido base por lo que
nuevamente es posible protón hartu
carbón y lo así que activemos lo este
carbono se vuelve más electro físico
lo que significa que el año en cloruro
puede actuar como núcleo filo y atacar
nuestro electro filo el año en cloruro
no es un buen núcleo filo por sí mismo
si el avión cloruro ataca aquí eso
empujaría a estos electrones al oxígeno
y podemos continuar dibujando lo que
formaremos tendríamos nuestro grupo r
tendríamos nuestro carbono tendríamos
este oxígeno con dos pares libres de
electrones enlazado a un hidrógeno aquí
mostremos a esos electrones en azul esos
electrones en azul se movieron al
oxígeno podemos decir que esos son estos
electrones
y luego podemos decir también que estos
electrones en verde en el año cloruro
formarán un enlace entre el cloro y el
carbono podemos continuar dibujando el
enlace entre el cloro y el carbono así
y aún tenemos nuestro oxígeno aquí
unido a nuestro azufre
doblemente enlazado a este oxígeno
y luego tenemos nuestro par libre de
electrones aquí y luego tenemos nuestro
cloro cierto
lo que todo esto hace es crear un grupo
saliente mucho mejor que con el que
empezamos podrías pensar en este como
nuestro grupo saliente este como un
grupo saliente en el siguiente paso del
mecanismo si volvemos a acá tenemos un
grupo saliente mucho mejor que el h con
el que empezamos y entonces si ese será
nuestro grupo saliente podríamos mostrar
a estos electrones de aquí moviéndose
acá para formar un doble enlace lo que
mandará a estos electrones a nuestro
oxígeno
continuamos mostrando lo que obtendremos
de eso
ahora formaremos nuestro grupo r un
carbono doblemente enlazado a nuestro
oxígeno
así un par libre de electrones y una
carga formal de más 1 y luego tenemos
aquí nuestro cloro con todos sus
electrones también
continuamos mostrando de dónde vinieron
esos electrones esos electrones se
movieron a acá eso volverá a formar
nuestro carbón y lo continuaré dibujando
eso y luego aún tenemos este enlace en
verde solo para hacerlo más claro
y luego tendremos unos electrones
hagamos los magenta estos electrones de
aquí se moverán al oxígeno podemos
continuar dibujando eso tendríamos
nuestro oxígeno con tres pares libres de
electrones
uno de esos serán los magenta podemos
continuar haciendo eso eso le da a
nuestro oxígeno una carga formal de
menos 1 porque está enlazado al azufre
aquí
el azufre aún está doblemente enlazado a
este oxígeno
aún hay un par libre de electrones en el
azufre
la razón por la cual este es un buen
grupo saliente es porque podemos mandar
a estos electrones a acá mover estos
electrones a acá y podemos formar
dióxido de azufre como un gas si
continuamos dibujando el resultado de
eso tendríamos ahora a este oxígeno
doblemente enlazado a este azufre
doblemente enlazado a este oxígeno
dibujamos nuestros pares libres de
electrones aquí
aún hay un par libre de electrones en
nuestro azufre si estos electrones de
aquí en rojo se movieron para formar
este enlace
bien ahora hemos formado dióxido de
azufre y también formamos una unión
cloruro nuevamente sigamos algunos
electrones si estos electrones se mueven
al cloro tenemos alañón cloruro ahora
tenemos a la unión cloruro
que podría funcionar como una base y en
el último paso de nuestro mecanismo de
es protón a tomar este protón dejando a
estos electrones atrás y finalmente
hemos formado nuestro cloruro de asilo
tenemos a nuestro carbono doblemente
unido a un oxígeno con dos pares libres
de electrones y tenemos a nuestro cloro
aquí así
si seguimos a esos últimos electrones
estos electrones en azul se movieron al
carbón y lo y entonces formarás hcl con
esto formarás h
cl y también es un gas la formación de
estos gases la formación del dióxido de
azufre y hcl nos lleva a completar esta
reacción ese fue un mecanismo largo y
nuevamente verás unas pequeñas
variaciones en esto si regreso acá
podrías mostrar este paso el núcleo filo
atacando al electro filo y formar
directamente esto si hubieras querido ya
que tu núcleo filo atacó al azufre estos
electrones se mueven al cloro
para formar el año en cloruro en este
paso y entonces obtendrás
esto
y luego también hablé de utilizar esto
como tu intermedio
dependiendo de cuál libro de texto
consultes de las pequeñas variaciones en
el mecanismo éste es un poco largo
bien veamos otras dos maneras de hacer
un cloruro de asilo
empezando con un ácido carboxílicos
puedes añadir venta cloruro de fósforo o
tri cloruro de fósforo y ambos te darán
un cloruro de asilo también y el
mecanismo es bastante similar y también
podemos pensar en lugar de three cloruro
de fósforo podemos añadir
r
33 bromuro de fósforo en lugar de poner
un cloro aquí pondremos un promo
y entonces podríamos formar un bromuro
de asilo de esta manera y veré un uso de
esta reacción en un futuro vídeo